foreign
hey how you doing we're doing great how
about you
I'm doing good doing good um well me and
my wife we got married back in uh 2020
during covid and um proceeding that oh
we just have a beautiful beautiful
little daughter just arrived three
months ago we paid off all of our
wedding that we had so we currently owe
zero dollars to anyone Excellent Car
Loan that we have yep thank you thank
you except for the call loan that we
have uh we do have a car loan so but
besides that we don't owe any money how
much is the car loan Our Salon the car
loan is about
um I think forty five thousand dollars
for a 74 month
um term so okay
arceland yeah you can't start a call
saying I don't owe anybody any money
except that's like saying I only eat
super healthy food except for twinkies
and Burger King and McDonald's and Taco
Bell yeah yeah I'm contradicting myself
over there how much do you make yeah
you're right uh well I make a 105 a year
with 15 annual bonus and my wife makes
about uh 55 with another 10 bonus for
her so in Queens it's a little bit above
minimum wage basically
yeah in Queens based out of Queens is a
little bit about the minimum wage so
yeah well here's the thing right so
we're currently renting right now and
we're paying about two thousand dollars
in one point one bedroom apartment and
we don't mind moving out to the suburbs
but in Long Island the houses are at
like 600 we currently have about 25
000 saved up okay and we just want to
know what we should do moving forward
like should we just rent rent save up
more or should we just take that money
and just buy yourself a house now I even
thought about buying myself a condo but
then the HOA fees here in Queens are
like a thousand dollars a month and I
don't want to throw money away like that
so what do you recommend that I do okay
this is really good I'm glad that you're
thinking about this I'm glad that you
hey I'm glad you got some money saved
that's great uh you do have the 45 000
in loans so can I just walk you through
um the principles here that we would
follow and then you can decide if you
like it or not basically okay so buying
a home is is super important right
everybody wants a home that's the
American dream it's we know it's a big
part of Building Wealth but on this show
we see time after time when people don't
do it the right way something that was
supposed to end up a blessing turns into
a bird and it turns into a headache it
turns into them having to sell a house
that they really love to keep and so I
want to keep that from happening to you
especially in an expensive place like
New York so what I would say first
things first A1 is let's get all this
debt paid off all right let's get rid of
this forty five thousand dollar car note
um and it's your choice you can either
pay it off pay off the 45 000 as it is
or you can try to downsize your car
um so that it's less debt and then pay
that off that sort of thing do you see
what I'm saying
so getting rid of that car loan because
we don't want to go into Home Ownership
saddled with debt because if anything
happens you know your home is on the
line right you got to be able to make
that payment so let's get clear of the
debt now the way we would suggest
clearing out that debt is this little
three-step process here we would say
have a thousand dollars saved first
that's your emergent that's your like
simple emergency fund right and so
you've got twenty five thousand dollars
saved so what I would suggest is taking
twenty four thousand of that twenty five
thousand and paying down this car
get it half gone down the car and then
pay off the rest of it you know working
hard and using you know your income
how quickly could you do that
um I we could we could do that within
like at least two years okay maybe even
us I bet less my concern yeah my concern
about that is
you know when it comes when it comes
down to cards I feel like let's say
let's not pay off the car and then the
next day tomorrow I get into a car
accident got a bit right yeah and if I
get into a car accident and I lose that
on the car and my insurance premium goes
up and then I also lose out on the money
that I just paid off the car with
whereas I have I have gap insurance and
like if gossip is something that's
happened to my car I feel like gap
insurance covers the remaining balance
of the car and it pays off the so you're
you're you're you're your plan in life
is to have a car payment for the rest of
your life so that if you ever get in a
car accident
you're not out money am I understanding
that correctly because if that's what
you're saying Our Salon I'm about to
make you look silly here on the radio
and I don't want to do it don't make me
look silly now no you arson you made
yourself look silly on this one come on
Arsenal I think that's just you saying I
don't want to come out of pocket to pay
this off because at the end of the day
you have insurance if something happens
they're gonna pay out yes you might not
get the exact value I mean that's just
part of it
um but you're still going to end up in a
better situation you're paid off seven
percent or eight percent against that 45
000 car over 72 months yeah for the
privilege of something that's probably
not gonna happen yeah you're you're
paying for the car three times over so
that you can avoid something that's not
even something you need to avoid
it doesn't make sense you know yeah that
makes sense that makes sense I get I get
where you're coming in from oh so you
recommend just pay off this car yeah
immediately get the debt cleaned up
immediately as quickly as possible take
on extra work to do it then stack up
that savings back up to 25 000. all
right then okay and only then because
you want to go into the home ownership
no debt with three to six months saved
okay and then we need to start talking
about the real cost around home
ownership because a lot of times we just
talk about the down payment and I'm like
no there's more to it than that when you
go to buy a house exactly I always tell
people keep This Acronym in your mind
you want a stacked deck DEC you need to
be ready for a down payment which could
be I don't know about five five to ten
percent for sure I'd say 10 to 20 yeah
yeah I mean that'd be nice but I'm not
mad if he gets it between
you know yeah as a 20 for a six hundred
thousand dollar house that's 120k look
the reason a lot of money we want you to
have a lot because we want you to have
Instant Equity and usually you need to
get somewhere between at least above
five percent because you don't want to
be you know try to get it 10 to 20. then
you want it you might have to do some
earnest money right sometimes they ask
you to put like one to three percent
down to say like yes I'm actually gonna
buy this house and then you've got your
closing costs and let me put on top of
that okay arsalon I'm all about it too
I bought my wife and I bought a house
it's incredible we love it we had it
inspected and then we had a couple of
different aspects of it inspected by
another professional
in the three years we've owned it
I've had to replace the roof
an air conditioner
uh we had to replace some water system
and then this past weekend we had the
electric guys out because something kept
tripping down in the basement and the
guys told my wife and I quote you're
going to want to sit down before I tell
you what actually is going on
oh wow the cost is staggering awesome
and maintenance right yeah well it's
just life happens man life happens and
so
um we want you to be ready yes here's
the thing there's been seasons of my
life when I would have thrown up at the
number they gave us I would have vomited
and then I've been trying to figure out
how to get out of this house
in this case because we followed this
plan all the way through it's annoying
pretty frustrating and the argument my
wife and I had was who had to call and
schedule it
not what car did we have to sell does
that make sense
guess what I'm afraid of is I'm afraid
of obviously dad but I'm also afraid of
the way you know like let's say I pay
the car off and I have money saved but
I'm paying rent every month and I feel
like I'm just throwing money away in a
trash can yeah I get that I get that but
you're not um my husband and I we rented
for 10 years and me and my wife rented
for Wow five to ten yeah also and it I
look what you're saying is not I get
that you do feel like it but when you
understand the intent behind it if you
understand the the end point the goal in
mind uh and keep your eye on that then
it kind of puts the rest of it into
perspective it's like no I'm not
throwing this money away I'm doing
something smart so that later I can't
you know so they can have the thing that
I want and you understand that there's
some link to that and it's not just uh
that decision to rent does not exist in
a bubble you know it's part of a plan of
everything else right so arsenaline let
me ask you a hard question
yeah if buying a house meant leaving New
York would you do it
yeah absolutely I've been telling my my
wife let's move to Texas but she doesn't
want to so well Texas is a long way from
New York but there's a lot of stops in
between but I'm seeing more and more and
more people say hey we want to have the
life we want over some magical
geographical location so if it means
going to Texas going to Kansas going to
Nashville we're gonna move and get the
house that we want